hanging their stockings de-snarled for
the sneer
tomorrow is christmas
it's practically here
in december of 1966 how the grinch stole
christmas premiered right here on cbs
and became an instant holiday classic
and the man who lent his voice as the
narrator to dr seuss's story
horror movie icon boris karloff
there's nothing to be afraid of
over his nearly six decade career
karloff appeared as some of the most
famous monsters in film history
including frankenstein's creature and
later the mummy
given his film history dr seuss thought
karloff would make the grinch too scary
for kids but grinch director chuck jones
best known for his work on looney tunes
was set on karloff from the start and
eventually dr seuss came around too
thomas hamilton is the director of the
new documentary boris karloff the man
behind the monster when dr seuss met
karloff he found him to be this
extraordinarily articulate cultured and
very very educated guy and
he quickly warmed to him when he
recorded the grinch karloff was 79 years
old and suffering from emphysema
but his performance was praised as
thoughtful and intelligent maybe
christmas he
thought doesn't come from a store
maybe christmas perhaps
means a little bit more
it's just the perfect quality that he
brings to this and it really it's why it
beats out anyone else that's tried to to
remake it since
the grinch earned karloff a grammy the
only major award of his career
and provided him with the largest
audience of any project he ever worked
on
one that grows with every showing
welcome christmas while we stand
heart to heart
and hand in hand